Salve youtubers e benvenuti nel video
per decretare il vincitore del concorso
scusate il ritardo di un paio di giorni
ma ho avuto un po' da fare Allora sarà
un video veloce e con video veloce
intendo non video breve ma video di
getto buttato lì perché siete stati
veramente tantissimi ma
tantissimissimissimi 120 di video
risposto una cosa
improponibile Veramente io vi ringrazio
con tutto il cuore io mi sono divertito
tantissimo a vedere le vostre recensioni
i vostri video ma adesso ne parlerò un
po' meglio allora a me sarebbe piaciuto
dire due parole su tutti i video ma
fisicamente non posso sennò veramente il
video verrebbe una cosa immensa e non
tutti lo guarderebbero perché lo
guardano solo lo guarda solo chi ha
partecipato al concorso quindi Bando
alle ciance Eh oggi non non pubblicizzo
nessun canale perché sarebbe inutile
pubblicizzo solo il mio io ho il secondo
canale ve lo ricordo soltanto ce l'ho da
un po' ve lo ricordo se volete
iscrivetevi perché arriveranno nuovi
video in questo periodo estate yeah non
ho niente niente da fare allora iniziamo
subito come al solito cioè come il
vecchio concorso
e il gruppo di finalisti diviso nei
finalisti che sono quelli che a
differenza Si sono un po' Fatti vedere
in positivo rispetto a tutti gli altri
partecipanti poi da questo gruppo
usciranno una manciata proprio pochi
finalis dissimi e tra questi finalis
issimi il vincitore
Ehm posso dire che è stato abbastanza
difficile scegliere soprattutto i
finalisti non tanto i finalis issimi Ma
i finalisti cioè il gruppone è stato
abbastanza difficile perché e non me ne
voglia nessuno cioè a me i video sono
piaciuti tantissimo mi mi avete fatto
vedere molte cose Siete stati bravissimi
quindi complimenti a tutti quanti solo
che non ne ho messi tantissimi perché
altrimenti avrei dovuto metterli tutti
perché io ogni volta che dicevo Guardavo
un video dicevo questo ragazzo Posso
metterlo o no vabbè lo metto ma allora
se metto lui poi poi devo mettere anche
quello di prima perché l'ho escluso ed è
più o meno simile Vabbè mettiamo anche
quello di prima ma allora se metto anche
quello di prima devo mettere anche i due
ragazzi di prima ancora e la la ragazza
ancora prima perché sono più o meno
uguali e vabbè mettiamo anche loro ma
allora e andava avanti così all'infinito
cioè avrei dovuto mettere tutti quanti
allora ho fatto che mettere quelli che
veramente si sono fatti vedere rispetto
agli altri e e in poi da questi ho tolto
i finalistii quindi iniziamo subito
non sono in ordine eh perché li ho visti
più volte anche se erano tanti e
soprattutto Scusatemi se non mi ricordo
perché io ehm perché molti mi dicevano
ehm ah condoglianze Ci sono 120 iscritti
Scusate se mi tolco gli occhi ma è
presto molti mi mandavano i messaggi
dicendomi Ah 120 video risposta
condoglianze perché no io li guardo
Appena arrivano Appena arrivano cioè io
io appena li vedo li accetto e li guardo
subito perché sennò veramente ci
metterei una vita
eh quindi li ho visti Cioè se il primo
video l'hanno mangiato il giorno dopo
cioè un mese fa Io l'ho visto un mese fa
È per questo che non mi ricordo bene
alcune cose quindi io l'ho scritti ma
non mi ricordo né Come si pronuncia né
effettivamente come come il bene cosa
diceva però se l'ho messo qui è perché
sicuramente meritava eh Tralasciando
questo un'altra cosa Ragazzi allora se
voi mettete un video di risposta A me
arriva la notifica su YouTube e e sulla
mail ok Io non ho fatto cioè ho ho messo
la cosa di accettare che io dovevo
accettare i video risposta Quindi voi me
lo mandav io lo accettavo e poi
compariva tra i video risposta c'è gente
che mi mandava un sacco di gente mi
mandava ho mandato il video risposta ma
non non l'hai ancora accettato come mai
guardo l'ora della mail le 3:00 del
mattino Ecco come mai non mi puoi dire
accetta il video alle 3:00 del mattino o
alle 4:00 di pomeriggio perché io esco
dormo Sai com'è Comunque no a parte
questi aneddoti ma mi sciavo Quando
arrivavano queste mail comunque
iniziamo Stratos Franky Scusate se non
riesco a leggere i nomi ma avete dei
Nick allucinanti Stratos Franky con il
destino del Cacciatore che dovrebbe
essere un libro di willb Smith se non mi
ricordo male una delle prime recensioni
veramente decenti poi ACD mix o ACD mix
con Forest Gamp il
film ensione bellissima lemy the best 85
con Thriller il video di Michael Jackson
bellissima anche questa molto specifiche
tutte e due sia quella di ACD mix che
quella dellem the best delios Guy
machina o machina o come volete dirlo
voi
ehm Ha recensito Experience un album dei
prodigi
ehm forse un po' un po' Cioè ti
come video Ma essendo uno dei tuoi primi
video quello che hai detto era molto
buono molto buono poi Riri kills you che
ha recensito un biscotto Un abbraccio
della Mulino Bianco recensione
fantastica Ma so che puoi fare molto di
meglio Riri hai i tuoi video vecchi
erano molto molto più belli
Probabilmente perché l'hai girato alle
6:00 del mattino tipo ma comunque
bellissimo you average Joy che sarebbe
il l'opinionista videoludico che ha
recensito the sky crawlers un anime un
film
eh bellissimo tu hai Usi delle parole
cioè Spero sia tutta farina del tuo
sacco ma credo di sì perché tutte le
recensioni sono così tue quindi Usi dei
paroloni molto molto tecnico molto
diciamo appesantito però sono delle
recensioni molto molto particolari molto
belle poi sbob sbob and Revelation Ah i
due ragazzi che hanno recensito risico
ecco
Spero che si pronunci così ma comunque
due ragazzi Simpaticissimi che hanno
recensito il gioco da tavolo risico
fantastico pcna con la Jones Eh boh la
recensione È buona però il video non
l'hai fatto per il concorso ma non
l'avevo detto e mi dovevo dirlo che mi
sono dimenticato però siccome non
avendolo detto va bene così recensione è
molto carina edigno 84 che ha ha
recensito i telefilm e i personaggi dei
telefilm risma di carta che ha recensito
Toradora Purtroppo questi non me li
ricordo bene però se li ho scritti
Scusatemi non me li ricordo bene però
comunque meritavano
parecchio nza 29 che ha recensito Fight
Club molto buona come recensione left
for game che ha recensito Alan Wake Ma
sei left for game che aveva fatto quel
casino di non votare quello lì Vabbè
lasciamo perdere stremis che ha
recensito Blade Runner è bravo è
bravo il tizio qualunque che ha
recensito Waking Life o Walking Life o
Waking Life Forse sia forse Waking Life
comunque una recensione bella come tuo
solito di un film molto particolare Tra
l'altro comunque Johnny 47 471 che ha
recensito la società la nostra società
recensione simpatica e molto molto molto
veramente carina Un po' di Diva dalle
altre dfi dfn che ha recensito totnes
che è una città di Londra Questa mi è
rimasta in particolare questa
recensione perché durante la recensione
la recensione è bella perché ha
recensito questa città di Londra che lui
ha visitato Ma durante la recensione ci
sono dei punti dei frame di filmato dove
c'è lui tipo vestito da vampiro comunque
un vampiro che appare durante il video
ma certi infatti infatti Da quando
appare la seconda volta che appare Io mi
sono C ho visto un video così perché io
sono impressionabile mi mi fai venire
degli infarti la recensione è buona
Peccato per quelle stronzate lì che
stavo per morire di infarto albo lewi
con l'enciclopedia dei mostri bella che
volevo comprare anch'io ma costa uno
sproposito e non l'ho fatto Anna Roberta
1986 che ha recensito
Twilight non in modo così negativo come
tutti potrebbero pensare una una
recensione Veramente bella è stata
quella poi squallor video Chan che hanno
recensito Assassin's Creed 2 recensione
carina
ariodb o arl ODB purtroppo l'ho scritto
male perché li ho scritti molto
velocemente eravate 120 che ha recensito
Splinter Cell punto CT che ha recensito
American Beauty anche questa una
recensione che non cioè di cui non
diceva che faceva parte del concorso
però comunque punto calt è bravissimo la
recensione di amicam Beauty è fantastica
tutta la sua una sua prospettiva
veramente bellissima Widow Black che ha
recensito Japanese
Magazine Bella Soprattutto molto
originale come come soggetto della
recensione dragonessa safira con Spyro e
a me piacciono lo sapete i video di
Dragon ea safira Infatti è questo mi è
piaciuto moltissimo veramente moltissimo
molto specifico Tra l'altro cioè si
vedeva che sapevi quello che dicevi
bello bello di tutti questi S si era per
quello che li ho scegli perché si vede
che sapevate di quello che stava dicendo
e non Non leggevate a caso così giusto
per fare una recensione poi Cool
production 93 con Shutter Island I am
Peter Cen con lei è troppo per me
veramente una recensione Cioè sei stato
veramente bravo sei bravo a parlare ehm
rocking Life che ha recensito il video
di
bellissima molto originale Cico 91 che
ha recensito
Glee Bella anche questa tutta gente
nuova che non avevo mai visto Mi Mi Mi
fa piacere eh guasta 11 che ha recensito
Scrubs che tra l'altro è uno dei miei
tel film preferiti recensione come al
solito molto personale molto originale
dal suo punto di vista poi matii con il
Bosco 1 che io non trovo e anche per
quello che non sono riuscito ancora
ancora riuscito a recensirlo l'hai fatto
tu e l'hai fatto in un modo fantastico
veramente bellissimo pieno di citazioni
da altre cose È bellissimo bellissimo
recensione divertente poi jor vlog che
ha recensito me allora molti hanno
recensito me quindi ho detto prendiamone
uno che rappresenti al meglio una
recensione su di me su Yotobi e joris
joris o joris Blog credo sia quello che
ha ha fatto recensioni migliore perché
ha messo critiche ha messo cose positive
l'ha detto con parole molto molto belle
molto lusinghiere Tra l'altro ti
ringrazio tantissimo ma non molto
esagerate a volte ehm e niente l'ha
detta parlando bene tutta senza mai
annoiare quindi mi è piaciuta parecchio
poi Victor lasl 88 con Arancia meccanica
e lo so mai voi molti Eh c'è Victor ll È
ovvio che l'avresti messo e purtroppo sì
c'è lui è bravo purtroppo e la dalla
recensione di Arancia Meccanica che tra
l'altro una delle migliori che ha fatto
secondo me e si vince che è bravissimo
quindi non potevo non metterlo purtroppo
7 minuti ok Non potevo non metterlo
purtroppo e è così è così the wood
Fridge che hanno recensito Sherlock
Holmes della asum tra
l'altro una una porcata allucinante e i
crul che ha recensito L'ultima legione e
filo 101 che ma credo sia filo 101 che
ha recensito Demon su che gioco della
Play 3 che io non conoscevo questo il
tuo il tuo canale sinceramente ed è
bello A me piace come parli Mi piace
veramente tantissimo quindi credo che ti
seguirò finiti Come vedete non sono
molti in confronto ai 150 ma ho ho
proprio preferito dividere tutti tutti
quanti perché c'erano alcuni questi
soprattutto che meritavano veramente
parecchio Allora
ehm e niente adesso vi dico i finalis
issimi che sono pochi sono 1 2 3 4 7 7
su 120
e sono un po' pochini però sono quelli
che veramente meritano meritano meritano
meritano meritano ed è
stato non dico difficilissimo perché io
sapevo già su chi puntare per per fare m
per per il vincitore finché non è
arrivato un altro Adesso vi spiego
allora i finalis issimi sono ACD mix con
Forest Gamp lemy the best con il video
di
Thriller l'opinionista video videoludico
you everage Joy con the sky crawlers
matios Ski con il Bosco 1 joris vlog con
la mia recensione e Victor lasl 88 con
Arancia Meccanica ah no scusate me ne
manca uno e Anna Roberta 1986 con
Twilight Ecco devo girare il foglio ogni
tanto se non mi dimentico Allora questi
sono le le le recensioni che secondo me
meritano di di di essere viste Non
meritano la mia approvazione meritano di
essere viste perché vi ricordo io non
posso non sono nella posizione di
giudicare però purtroppo ho fatto un
concorso quindi devo giudicare non sono
nella posizione perché le mie recensioni
fanno cagare ma comunque fatto sta
Allora iniziamo con escluderne una
subito la recensione di joris vlog
Purtroppo la devo togliere cioè l'ho
messa perché hai detto bellissime cose
hai fatto critiche su di me giuste
neanch'io sarei riuscito a iscrivermi
meglio Te l'ho scritto anche nel
commento sei bravo a parlare hai detto
L'hai detto in un italiano corretto non
sei stato mai noioso quindi l'ho voluta
premiare premiare il tuo canale anche
per dire cioè il prossimo che ascolta
questa recensione magari va a vedere il
canale l'ho fatto apposta però la devo
togliere perché non è un'effettiva
recensione di un oggetto un un film
comunque una cosa fisica ma sono io che
teoricamente sono una cosa fisica Ma
avete capito cosa intendo quindi la
tolgo e rimangono queste tre 4 se allora
allora vado per
esclusione tolgo Però non so cioè adesso
ci sto pensando adesso non so per cosa
togliervi Allora dovrei togliere perché
so qual è il vincitore ma non ho non mi
sono studiato il perché devo togliere le
vostre Allora togliamo l'opinionista
videoludico Allora tolgo l'opinionista
di videoludico perché è molto molto e lo
saprai anche tu molto molto pesante Cioè
non pesante come recensione molto
pompata come se fosse Cioè come se
stessi leggendo Dorian gry c'è una roba
proprio pompata devi proprio stare
attento attento Attento attento Ma
proprio fissato con il video per capire
ogni singola parola che dici però quando
vai a capire ogni singola parola che
dici la recensione è fantastica Il
problema è che devi avere il 100% di
attenzione però mi piace un sacco come
lo fai tu credo con After Effect o
comunque con qualche programma dove
metti la tua faccia che parli e sotto
molto più grande una finestra con le
immagini del video sincronizzata al
parlato fantastico una cosa bellissima
Il problema è che è molto pompata la
recensione lo saprai anche tu tu scrivi
così a me piace però a molto
puoi far perdere l'attenzione Cioè se
uno si si distrae un attimo perde un
sacco delle cose che hai detto e
soprattutto è più facile distrarsi con
una recensione del genere quindi lo
tolgo per questo ma complimenti perché
sono veramente bellissim Ah invito i i
finalis issimi non tutti i finalisti Ma
i finalis issimi solo Perché senò si
crea un altro concorso e non serve
mettere il video il video togliere il
video di risposta dal concorso e
metterlo qua sotto così la gente lo può
vedere poi
tolgo
lemmy the best
85 perché ti tolgo lemy the best 85
Forse perché cioè una cosa che ho
riscontrato è che parli un po'
lentamente però parli bene Dici cose
giuste dici cose interessanti dici cose
senza mai annoiare hai recensito
thriller una cosa dando delle
informazioni che non sapevo che non
sapeva chi ha visto il video fantastico
un video fantastico però devo toglierlo
perché il
vincitore l'unico motivo per cui vi
tolgo è perché il vincitore ha qualcosa
in più poi ve lo faccio vedere quindi io
ti tolgo comunque video fantastici se
sono tutti fantastici Cioè vi Tolgo solo
perché ripeto perché il vincitore ha una
marcia in più allora poi tolgo am mal in
cuore ma Anna Roberta 1986 con la
recensione di
Twilight m Allora questa è stata una
recensione che mi è piaciuta parecchio
perché la penso uguale ed identica a lei
nonostante cioè
Anche perché l'ha fatta bene l'ha detta
bene in italiano senza mai annoiare che
sono cose importanti anche e questo ve
lo dico adesso anche con
un'illuminazione decente perché c'è
gente Ho visto che fa le rensioni contr
controluce con la serranda abbassata no
cioè non vedo niente perché se voi fate
i video con la webcam non è un problema
ma se li fate con la webcam che ha una
risoluzione orribile controluce con la
serranda abbassata viene un quadrato
nero Il video non si vede niente quindi
cercate anche anche quello conta nella
perché se io devo ascoltare fare Voi
fate una recensione anche magari un po'
un po' lenta dove non si vede niente
Dove l'illuminazione è
terribile tra l'altro c'è gente che urla
in casa ma non importa perdo la
concentrazione si perde la
concentrazione quindi viene un po' una
porcheria comunque tolgo Anna Roberta
vediamo
perché perché era molto molto personale
questa era abbastanza tecnica però
Queste erano praticamente il 90%
opinioni tue che è una cosa fantastica
perché stessa cosa le recensioni che
faccio io
però niente cosa mi invento per
togliermi mi dispiace un sacco togliermi
Mi dispiace perché Erano fantastiche Io
vi invito a vederle chi guarda il video
vi invito a vedere le le recensioni
perché sono fantastiche e lei ha detto
che cioè Twilight non è così brutto come
tutti pensano Cioè è un po' Strano come
film come l'hanno impostato però è così
e quindi mi sembra stupido
è quello che penso io mi sembra stupido
sparare a zero su Twilight Cioè anche
gente che non ha visto Twilight dice che
è una merda po una contraddizione ma
comunque è questo che mi è piaciuto
della recensione poi lei parla molto
bene e niente il ti too Forse perché al
90% erano più opinioni tue che è una
vera e propria
recensione poi rimangono matii Victor
lasl e accid mix Allora
tolgo
matii lo tolgo perché
Eh la recensione forse era un
po' un po' esagerata Cioè era più un
una come le mie cioè io tolgo recensioni
molto simili alle mie sono un idiota
però è vero purtroppo era molto recitata
No molto esagerata anche a volte
Sembrava quasi una un monologo teatrale
più che una vera e propria recensione
proprio come un Cantico dei Cantici una
roba fantastica cioè fantastica da
vedere Effettivamente Però tra le
recensioni dei vincitori del vincitore
dei due finalisti Diciamo che è quella
meno meno meno recensione però è
fantastic Cioè è come un video comico
più che una recensione Il tuo ed è
bellissimo anche perché oltre a far
ridere tu spieghi anche delle cose però
in in maniera minore però cioè lo sai e
cioè io non ho detto non non prendo
matioski perché fa già video No no no
questa volta non l'ho fatto perché molti
facevano video Quindi avrei dovuto
escludere tutti i più bravi non potevo
farlo allora tra rimangono Victor lasl e
AC di
mix Io tra questi due c'era un vincitore
Io ho detto Ah è arrivata la sua
recensione Vince lui poi ne è arrivata
un'altra e e ho e ha traballo la mia la
mia decisione ho traballa un po'
Allora allora descriviamo le tutte e due
Victor laslo 88 Ha recensito Arancia
Meccanica l'ha recensito con
criterio riuscendo a stare nei 10 minuti
dicendo un sacco di cose riuscendo a far
vedere addirittura un trailer
e avendo opinioni obiettive e opinioni
sue fantastico ACD mix l'ha fatta con
criterio con obiettività e con opinioni
sue ci ha messo in sottofondo Credo una
musica fantastica che credo sia proprio
la colonna perché lui parla anche della
colonna sonora di Forest Gamp mettendoci
quindi credo in sottofondo Forest gum
oppure un'altra canzone ed era
azzeccatissimo per per quello che ha
detto quindi chi togliere chi togliere
chi togliere alla
fine sono rimasto della mia idea
iniziale Dopo varie lotte sono rimasto
della mia idea iniziale quindi il
vincitore del concorso è ACD mix
complimenti perché quella cè appena
l'hai fatta vedere Cioè l'hai messa
Mizzica Cioè mi è piaciuta subito un
sacco per quel per quello che hai detto
per quello che hai detto per come l'hai
detto per come hai descritto Forest Gamp
per i particolari che ci hai messo hai
descritto la colonna sonora hai fatto
vedere il i DVD edizione speciale con
due dischi tutti i cd della colona
sonora l'ho spartito hai messo una
musica in sottofondo fantastica e hai
parlato senza mai annoiare ehm hai detto
cose non mai
sbagliate obiet con le tue opinioni
dicendo che sono tue opin c'era di tutto
in quella recensione in 10 minuti c'era
di tutto e di più tutto giusto tutto
giusto tutto giusto a me non dico che ha
emozionato perché era una recensione
però mi hai fatto ricordare quanto è
bello Forest gum ho visto che ti è
piaciuto un sacco ed filmone allucinante
e quindi vinci tu per questo cioè Victor
lasl l'ha fatta in egual modo bene però
m eh perché cioè però è molto più
toccante quasi la tua Sarà stata la
musica in sottofondo non lo so però
veramente era proprio bella bella bella
la tua quindi il vincitore sei tu che
tra l'altro tu non ti chiami mix 939
perché io ti seguo E se è un canale che
che seguo anche se fai video acquisti tu
Sol di solito di manga Comunque fatti
sentire lo il premio lo scegliamo
insieme Faccio scegliere a te se ti devo
inviare un film se vuoi fare una
recensione insieme la sponsorizzazione
del canale è un quello che vuoi ti do il
mio cane perché lo sto odiando Inti
giorni e te lo invio in busta chiusa
dici dove abiti e niente quindi fatti
sentire Mi raccomando voi finalis issimi
ficcate il video di risposta qua sotto
così almeno la gente lo può vedere se
volete criticare la le scelte che ho
fatto scrivete un commento non dovete AV
paura Cioè non dovete dire Ah vi non non
metto un commento perché poi la gente
dice che mi che rosico del fatto che non
ho vinto probabilmente la gente lo farà
però fregatevene così almeno mi fate
sapere se la vittoria è è stata giusta
cioè Se voi mi dite di no non non è che
cambio idea Non è che faccio un altro
video però almeno si può un attimo
discutere quindi ci vediamo alla
prossima recensione che non so quando
arriverà
e vi ricordo il secondo canale Se volete
iscrivetevi e niente quindi ci
vediamo Un Un saluto ad CD mix mix 939
Non lo so
e niente saluti